[Music]
put your foot on and hang on oh oh it's
very rewarding as volunteer seeing
seeing the smiles on people's faces and
the enjoyment they're getting out of it
it couldn't be more rewarding
so hit the little brush I see Jordan and
once a week used on a Sunday afternoon
and will spend maybe four or five hours
together
Jordan has lost this they're dead some
time ago and I've been able to do some
of the you could say main things in his
life and it's really satisfying to see
him sort of become more confident so
something that I really enjoy doing
Thanksgiving success with the volunteer
whether we're only too happy to help
[Music]
the aims are actually taking through
from from waste that was going you know
just into waste and giving it to people
who are hungry seem to me something that
I really want to be involved with
we've got a great band of volunteers
people who give up the time to do this
highlight for me is to see the community
and see the people go out of you
big smile face goose with new cannon is
not easy
[Music]